okay everybody I am really excited today
because I am joined by Sarah Sokolov ik
from big little eyes who plays Tori and
you also might have seen her in homeland
as Laura Sutton and she's done many
plays as well and other feature roles in
television Sarah how are you today
oh hi C's I'm good what a sweet
introduction and thank you for
pronouncing my name correctly you've
done right by me as many of my former
teachers have not pass thank people
people have been butchering my name
since I was a wee little child yeah out
of anything I was most nervous out of in
this interview was pronouncing your last
name right so I'm happy I have passed so
I wanted to address the big elephant in
the room and when I did research on you
as a person is it true that you worked
at a zoo before you acted oh yeah I did
actually yeah my first job that I ever
had was at the Milwaukee County Zoo
mainly I worked in guest services so it
was like taking money for parking and
renting strollers that were shaped like
dolphins and a tree occasionally I got
to be the train conductor like there's a
little train that runs through the zoo
so I'd sit in the last car and tell kids
to keep their arms in the windows and
not throw rocks but really they're
reserved generally like no animals
involved with the works at the zoo but I
do I do really love animals I actually
wanted to be a vet okay okay so you
weren't like the position at the zoo
that if a gorilla got out of line you
had to make the decision of whether to
put it down or not yeah no like once I
worked at the giraffe encounter which I
I loved because I loved your ass they're
so regal but I think basically I was
just like selling tickets and they got
to take a picture with the giraffe or
feed them wrong I don't remember that
too well but I do yeah there was no
animal handling in my job at the zoo so
how in your life like did you know then
like you're someone who loved animals
we're gonna sue but then were you
fitting in acting on the side here when
did you start getting
an actress is this something that's been
with you since like childhood I mean I
you know I want it I was really I wanted
to be a lot of stuff as a kid I remember
there was a sense where I wanted to be
an astronaut I really wanted to be a
journalist for a while actually I almost
went to school to study classics like
Latin Greek dead languages being an
actor is kind of perfect though if you
stick around long enough you can play at
a lot of different things without the
high stakes it's the actual job right I
know I don't think it actually hits for
me until maybe I was in my 20s I started
doing community theater when I was about
16 before that I think I'd done like one
walk-on in a play as a small child but
what I loved about theater was the
community that I found I think I had a
hard time feeling like I fit in
everywhere else right um
I was bullied a fair amount in school
like not like a lot of people are and I
was a really really really shy shy kid I
had a hard time putting words to my
thoughts and my feelings and my theater
friends that I made were from all walks
of life and they loved me just the way
that I was I had I'd had some dance
training and loved dancing because you
didn't have to sort of talk to express
yourself so I did a ton of theater
anywhere I could and then I think I got
my first professional gig when I was
probably about 19 did a bunch of
regional theater moved to New York did
more theater anywhere I could and then I
auditioned and got into Yale Yale School
of Drama when I was about 28 right but I
can't say I know exactly when and where
I committed to the idea of acting as a
profession even though I'd been getting
paid to do it professionally since it
was pretty young it was just part of my
identity for for so long so would you
say then when you say about bullying and
I think anyone entertainment can relate
to that would you say that it was like a
big benefactor to to like pushing you
like tour
acting and acting became like this
outlet for you and something that kind
of how it heals that stuff you went
through that trauma in a way oh for sure
I mean it's hard to kind of unpack the
entire experience but I really just
loved I'm one of those actors that loves
the feeling of disappearing into
something you know and in disappearing
into something you can also reveal a lot
about yourself I think in a very safe
way but also in it but it's even if it
feels dangerous at the time you know to
sort of tell your own personal truth
through another person um yeah it was
just a really great it was the perfect
it was sort of the perfect things for me
I got to express myself and I was with a
lot of other different kinds of people
that you know probably also didn't fit
in everywhere else and yeah it was just
sort of it was as just the happiest
accident of my life and I happened to
you know stumble into doing community
theater sometimes it's funny but
honestly I was probably the happiest
that I had ever been in my entire life
doing doing like a community theater
musical it was so much fun there's no
paycheck involved you know everybody
just rolling up their sleeves and have
to put the show on and all ages all
types ethnicity sexual orientations it's
just you know I really I really just
felt like it was I belonged there yeah
yeah that's that's awesome Sarah and
saying that now about like community
theater and you have such a strong
background in theatre I'm curious how
was that transition then when you first
started doing television or film and
just the differences and challenges you
kind of face between the different types
of acting in a way well yeah I mean I've
I've been lucky that I've had a fairly
prolific career in the theatre I mean
I've done so many plays musicals
I noticed that I've been given a lot
more opportunities to do wildly
different parts like
you said on stage and so hopefully
that'll carry over into my camera work
some more diversity I've gotten to do a
lot of different kinds of stuff on
camera already but for me there's some
big tactical differences I mean there's
things that you can get away with
vocally on camera that might not carry
well on stage depending on the space
that you're playing and there's things
that you can do physically on stage that
might not work for film or TV depending
on what kind of film and television that
you're doing with film there's more
opportunities to improvise then I've
gotten with the theater which sort of
theater sort of requires you to be
specific with your consistencies to keep
a show intact for a long run and then
there's prep I mean in preparation for a
play you have the luxury of rehearsing
for a long period of time and then
previews and then performance after
performance to explore but you know
transitioning from that experience to
the film and TV experience I have to say
finishing a take on film and then
getting to walk away from it it's
totally satisfying for someone who has a
ridiculous perfectionist it's been
really really good for me and um I'm not
very precious about my choices I can
kind of do something and then let it go
I don't need to go back to the same
thing all the time but I find myself to
be even less Precious about my choices
on camera and I think you know film and
TV is sort of the undiscovered country
for me right now there's built like so
much that I want to accomplish there and
I'm having such a great time with my
camera work but at the end of the day
you know you choose I choose work based
on writing if I loved the writing and
all I feel like I have to do is mind the
text and I'm taken care of I let it
challenge yeah I love I love a big
challenge so so to her to do you know
another theater piece I think I would
want it to be something that I could
really really fail at you know something
that I've just never done before right
now I have no idea what that would look
like because I've just had so much
experience in the theater so
I'm open I'm open to the to being
surprised sure and I would say you're
very versatile actress and it's already
so impressive you've been nominated for
award in theater and nominated for ward
in homeland for TV so having said that
getting nominated for these big awards
how did that affect your perspective of
yourself as an actress does it like
alter your ego in a way and is it good
is it bad would you say well yeah I was
so there was a Drama Desk Award Best
Featured Actress in a Musical for the
Shaggs at Playwrights Horizons and that
was kind of crazy
I really wasn't expecting it you know
the I think the nominations come out
like a year they came out like a year
after I had actually done the musical
and then for homeland we were nominated
as Best ensemble for the Screen Actors
Guild Awards and personally I think I
felt more comfortable being part
nominated as part of an ensemble because
I just have this weird thing about being
singled out of a group because I just
know how hard everyone works and I
remember that when I was nominated as a
single performer I tried to think about
it as being the opportunity as being
given to talk about the work that we all
did collectively and I think you know
being nominated for things it's really
nice
it gets you some attention and attention
guests you on lists and lists can get
you into rooms that you haven't been in
before or rooms that are just like
impossible to get into but at the end of
the day you know the great reward for me
is the job it's just all about getting
to do the work so I tried I try to think
about it more like that versus looking
at it like you know you're singled out
because you were the the best I know the
best of the best I try to think about it
as oh wow this is great this is another
opportunity for me to get get more
opportunities to do what I love so
that's what you say that too and like
saying about you get put more on lists
and more opportunities kind of arise
from that but also I was wondering
with that I'm sure comes a little more
pressure did you have a moment where you
felt a lot of pressure for the first
time in your life as you went up the
ladder like any certain auditions or
where you kind of felt that change yeah
I mean definitely yes is the short
answer I think I think I've always
struggled with anxiety
auditions are terrible situations to be
put in some context I try to look at
them it's just an opportunity to act and
just an opportunity to show you know my
ideas and what what I can do really well
but they're very they're very hard I
mean like you're you're often not given
very much time at all to prepare for
these things especially if you know you
you're at the level that I've been at
for most of my life you you have you
know maybe if you're lucky 48 hours to
prepare you know a week is a luxury and
that's actually not a lot of time for an
actor to prepare for a role so it's
always been a challenge for me to go
into the room and not feel like I'm
taking a test and the test is how well
do I know my lines so once I can kind of
get past that sort of roadblock most of
the time it's just about whatever I'm
you know whatever love I'm bringing into
the room with me which I know it sort of
sounds hippy but you know the love for
that character the love for the story
the love for the work of the people that
I'm in the room with auditioning but
it's surprising though you know some of
the big ones some of the really big ones
like the homeland audition for for
example I just really thought that
character was fun I really felt like I
understood it in a very instinctive way
and the you know I was meeting with the
executive producers it was a big deal I
was the only person called that day so
it was like a very private meeting with
me and when I walked in I think I wasn't
really aware of how big a deal it was I
certainly didn't know that they were
going to take that tape and make it a
test the network I didn't know any of
that and so in some ways it actually
worked
for me because I could relax a little
bit and I remember when I talked to Alex
Danza the executive producer after you
know when we were in Berlin he said oh
you were just so beautifully confident
and I thought god that's so funny
because I don't I just don't I don't
really remember it like that I remember
that I was a little nervous but that I
just really loved that part and so I
think I try to let the you know the love
that I have for you know getting to act
and that role come out more I try to
have that featured in the foreground
conversions right whatever anxiety is
kind of happening okay that's that's
awesome that you do that and it sounds
like you're very deep in thinking and I
think that are always successful though
it's not always successful
definitely not I've certainly had a lot
of faith plans and sometimes it's like
I'm pretty shy and so I have that
nervous talking thing and sometimes
people just find it adorable in the room
and sometimes it probably just makes me
look like a total idiot but you know
whatever so you say you're pretty shy
too so would you would you put yourself
in that category because a lot of
comedians a lot of actors too like
people don't realize you meet them in
person and a lot of them are shy it's a
oh yeah it's a normal thing and like but
you're able to like turn something on
when you're on a stage or in a set it's
almost like all that I guess
self-confidence that you've kind of
suppressed in your life comes out there
right I feel like I can even relate to
that when I'm just doing my videos and
it's like would you say though you're
just naturally a shy person you can but
you do have a switch you can like kind
of come out of it yeah I think um you
know for me it's all it's all in the
it's all just I put all of all the work
in civic the character and I'm not
really one of those actors that I'm not
super you know I hate using the word
method but I'm not that actor that needs
to sort of be in character the entire
time on the set but you do sort of
change your focus a little bit so that
the things that can kind of trigger your
anxiety like all of the people the chaos
that's happening around you you know
just trying
you know recall your lines effortlessly
all of the things that could make you
nervous I really just try to focus on
the character what they're there to do
that day in the scene what they're
pursuing I try to put it all into that
and and just kind of recognize you know
the the little monsters in your head the
little anxiety is just little gremlins
that are running around the room you
know that they're there yes but you're
not gonna pay any attention to them my
friend Vicki actually put it to me that
way once she said you just got a picture
them as gremlins like they're out there
they're running around they're doing
they're saying but you're not gonna pay
attention to them right now you're just
gonna focus on what your job is I like
that your friend Vicki's very smart yeah
okay so switching gears now to big
little eyes obviously the show that is
huge on HBO
you play Tori on it obviously now when
you got cast in such a big show as big
little eyes did you know right away when
you got this part that it what exactly
it was and who was actually in the show
I did know I I remember that when I
auditioned I knew who was attached that
had been attached thus far and I don't
know I think when you get things like
that I mean there's been so many I've
been really fortunate that I've gotten
an audition for some really high-profile
stuff I mean my team has just worked so
hard for me and which is lucky like I
knew that there was some really huge
people involved and I just looked at it
like oh well this would be just so great
to get you know to get to be a part of
but it didn't um it didn't like totally
freak me out
I mean I had had the fortune of working
with a lot of really huge actors already
and in a really deep and intimate way I
mean there was homeland you got Claire
Danner one it was like a total class act
asked Marie friggin Abraham Mandy
Patinkin John Turturro had directed me
as an understudy in a Broadway play and
I mean that right there just checks off
a lot of people and you know that are on
the please let me work with in some
capacity like it
yeah and I did a planned it's in New
York City called Detroit with John
column Daren petty David Schwimmer and
Amy Ryan and it was a huge role a
coveted role and I absolutely loved it
and I remember them when we read through
the play for the first time Amy turned
to me at the end of it and of all the
things she could have done or said in
that moment the first thing that she
said was you are just fantastic and wow
what a gift I mean I felt like oh okay I
actually do belong here I have a job to
do that I can do well because once you
hear that from you know someone who's an
idol and she absolutely is she's truly
an idol of mine she's a total genius
she can do anything not just those
experiences stay with you forever sorry
I remember like thinking oh this is just
an incredible opportunity right and this
would be really cool to get but you know
I've worked with they're all just actors
and if they're actors worth their salt
they're there to show up and just get
the work done and just do a good job and
they are you know yeah they're really
committed to what they're doing so so it
sounds like you were already like
prepared to even just be like okay yeah
my scene partner in the scene is Reese
Witherspoon and you had enough almost
veteran acting experience around other
big-name actors and actresses and I
think that's really cool how you just
put that there that again to everyone's
there to do their job and and I feel
like too like when you're gonna scene in
example big little eyes with Reese
Witherspoon you're able right to Zone in
and just almost forget that it's even
Reese Witherspoon realize it's Madelyn
and eventually you just almost are like
oh we're all on the same team here I'm
assuming that's how you feel on set with
them yeah I mean there's always there
yes there's always them there is a
moment here there of oh my god this is
crazy but really it's a job and if you
made it to where you are then you have
to just focus on the job because
ultimately your scene partner needs you
and I work just really hard at just
trying to be a great scene partner just
be a great assist you know do your home
listen well stay flexible be present
because that's the real gift that you
can give to the process okay so with a
character now like Tori to me watching
it and seeing you on screen I always saw
in the back of my head like man this
must be a tough part to play because to
the audience it's a very mysterious
character especially when you just come
in and all we really know about you is
that you're Joe's wife in the beginning
and that you got your eye on Madeline so
when you're going in as the actress of
this character are you creating a whole
backstory for her in your head are you
on like kind of sync with the writers
about this or is there like a little
loose thing you got there that's just
open I don't know how to exactly say
that but oh yeah what do you think it's
so funny you saved this season it's like
she's not a mystery to me because I know
all their secrets like evil laugh but
Tori's like Tori is a great what I
affectionately have referred to in my
life as a ninja role you know she just
gets in there she slices some folks up
and she gets out and sometimes those are
just the my favorite parts because I
feel a lot of Liberty to play create
things in my mind that maybe the
audience will only ever see pieces of
what makes this person but my theory is
if you really do your homework the
audience might not always get the
specific full picture of exactly what
they're seeing from you at every moment
but they'll hopefully see a really rich
three-dimensional person with a full
inner life who arrives at an inevitable
moment in their lives that's always my
hope anyway and usually if someone uses
the word mystery it means they want to
know more about the thing they're
talking about so I'll take it that's
that's very flattering do you though
with that character when you're on set
and you're like okay this is my script
for the character or their moments where
you do go to like the director or write
and be like hey so can you give me a
little intel where Tori's headed or or
do they oh yeah okay yeah I mean you
never really know much of anything ahead
of time on you know in TV or at least I
I've never been in the position where I
have like
you know with the show and with homeland
it's you know everyone's kind of a
spoiler alert so they don't really want
to tell you too much ahead of a time
ahead of time I do speak up if something
really and truly doesn't make sense to
me at all but you know it's kind of a
neat nature of the beast
but that can be okay I always look at it
as if you don't have more than a few
pages to go on you just tell the truth
of the moment in the moment as it is on
the page and you trust that it will all
unfold as it's meant to and no one no
one expects the Spanish Inquisition
right I hope the kids listening or
listen to this great advice so now when
you first read the part of Tori did you
have any characters you played in
theater or on screen before that you
kind of connected tutorial maybe helped
you get into the mindset of her
character or was it something totally
brand-new to you as a character totally
you know she's pretty freshly-baked
she's totally a new one
for me or I look at her that way but
maybe that's why she's so fun I will say
ironically just sidebar when we were
filming season 1 the big Audrey Elvis
party scene near the end of the season
Beyonce had just dropped lemonade and my
god it could not have been more perfect
timing number one am a huge Beyonce fan
but it was it was like the perfect
soundtrack to sort of have in my head as
that character I remember I think back
to the the audition and season one and
how there wasn't much time to prepare so
you sort of have to respond to what
speaks to you this early trust your
instincts your first impressions and I
remember that one of the audition scenes
was the scene where a Tory confronts
Madeline at the opening night party for
Avenue Q which Joseph my husband
directed and that really spoke to me
that felt very unique because not every
person would do something like that
that's a very specific human being
confronting a private issue in a public
space and I just saw her as a decent
kind honest person who loves her husband
and was just wanting the truth despite
whatever pain she was going through
whatever answer she was going to get and
I often wonder what that scene would
have looked like if Madeline would have
just told her the truth because I mean
Tory doesn't walk up to her and say you
know a bunch of expletives she gives her
the opportunity to just be authentic in
the moment with her and she asks her was
it you and that's a super vulnerable
thing to do and shortly after that I was
tasked I I had a costume fitting and it
was actually the designer Alex who
offered up that they were kind of
thinking of Tory as someone who was not
as money as everyone else that she and
Joseph were sort of newer to the area
and just that little piece of
information I mean it really lit me up I
thought oh wow okay great so she's
married to an artist maybe Tory's also
an artist her clothes are kind of worn
in and comfortable very bohemian style I
think the car I drove is like an old
Saturn yes you know lower economic
standing and then all of that kind of
becomes pieces of a puzzle then you know
you think about how she probably felt
like a bit of an outsider no real strong
sense of community maybe not in the way
that Joseph had maybe no strong
friendships maybe her confidence was
suffering because she wasn't as rich and
popular as everyone else and the scripts
never spoke about children so you know
maybe they don't have any maybe she
deeply wanted them and that also
separates her from the rest of the
communities so then you basically come
up with this picture in your head you
know warm kind decent person in a
community not totally comfortable and
pushed into a humiliating position so in
a last-ditch effort to get some clarity
move on from this she confronts Madelyn
and the response she gets is that she's
treated this is nothing ever happens
mm-hmm you know nothing's even happened
and now you got a character who feels
invisible and I think that's a very
human thing that many people can connect
to well then you have to
and I can just go like a thousand
different ways that can motivate so many
different outcomes for you know for
future act actions I think that's a
great setup really enjoying that that
was excellent really no I probably just
went to the mind Ettore I actually
forgot I was interviewed too I thought
[ __ ] it and I mean oh yeah and I think
that's what makes her character so
interesting and how like when we meet
her in season one she really is one of
the only true to me victims in the show
and we've only seen good from her we're
like everyone else there's dirt
obviously and there's a lot of gray but
I'm rooting for Torrey but then it's
like I wonder watching season two like
hmm I wonder where Tori's gonna go and
if she's gonna be as likable as we move
on um I think that's very interesting
and I was hard to tell with this show
especially I mean it's it's hard it's
hard to know and you know I guess by
definition yes she's a she's a victim in
the sense that from what we've seen
she's sort of the casualty of some folks
who chose to like blow up their lives
sure but I don't think you know I don't
think she has that victim mentality I
think that what we've gotten to see from
her so far is that she's working really
hard at picking herself up and and
living or a really full life you know
that's the thing though I wonder with
her is like cuz you know affairs and
cheating everyone is her different views
on all this stuff but oh yeah I I wonder
like is she a character would you say
Tori if you're gonna rank like how mad
she is that Jo her husband versus how
mad she is at Madelyn because some
people usually are just mad at their
spouse for affairs but some people
actually take it I think more out on the
mistress and they go slash their tires
or something like where do you see
Tories like belief on that well I will
say that I don't think Madelyn is her
favorite person okay okay so she's not
like totally blind to the other person
like she's not just like so focused on
the spouse right I think I think she
kind of has the full the full picture
okay of what of what's going on okay
okay
it's like it's so funny you don't want
to like you know you don't want to say I
love given having letting the audience
just have as much of their own
experience as they can watching this
show so it's like I even feel a little
bad you know just for going into Tory's
mind a little bit because I like that
people will watch something and they'll
just they'll just have their own you
know completely own experience they'll
have their own feeling about you know
what they're seeing to speak to what's
aired this season like in the first
episode I mean we just don't have enough
time on the show for me to talk about
how disarmingly cool Adam Scott is sure
sure and what he's just such a great guy
I just think the world of them I mean I
will say I was nervous there because I
just think he's really brilliant and I
wanted to show up well for him I wanted
to be a really good assist she's so much
fun so focused and oh man when you have
moments on set which are so chaotic and
awkward and unnatural feeling for me
still with all the people in the
equipment and the start and stop when
you have someone as a partner who's just
really tuned in like he is it's it's
gold and yeah yeah he made it so easy
for me and so you know yeah I I have to
say that a lot of that I found a lot of
myself in in in working with Adam you
know in that first yeah particularly in
that first scene because you show up you
have these ideas but they they really
don't mean anything until you're with
the director and you're your scene
partner right now that scene too made
such a big stamp just even on social
media and Twitter yes totally now to be
gotta be honest with me here when that
premieres airing are you like going on
the couch cooking of some 500 or and
what no okay nope I'm like hiding okay
doing something else no I don't really I
think it sounds bad not to offend anyone
and I don't really don't I don't watch I
really don't
hey that nope yeah
in the first season I watched everything
basically that I wasn't in and I watched
the last episode which I am in but they
don't I don't really talk in it so I
figured that that was fine I'm just
terrible at watching herself it's sad I
can't ever
I've heard that Conan O'Brien has that
has like the thing where he'll read
something about himself and then he'll
pick out the one thing they're not
really negative yeah I you know I'll
watch a scene and I'll think about like
something physical that I have zero
control over or how my voice sounds or
whatever and and I think you know if an
experience means something to you it's
hard to then watch the videotape of what
that experience was they cut it and they
use you know stuff that you know you
might not have it I just I just stay out
of it I stay away from social media land
just because it all freaks me out okay
yeah because I was gonna ask you that
because that was one of the things I
always notice when I'm like oh I like
this actress or actor I'll look them up
on Instagram and Twitter when they're
not there I think I maybe I'm spelling
the name wrong longer like no there's no
Sara here so that's a conscious decision
and is there like are you anti-social
meteors just not for you yeah I mean I
know the world's like deprived of my
pictures as my homemade pies and my
adorable puppy dog no I think I used to
have all I had most of that stuff and I
think I quit it when I realized I mean
there were probably a lot of different
reasons but I think I quit it once I
realized that if you post a picture the
company owns it forever oh god okay even
if you like delete it or delete your
profile and I didn't like that I don't
know if that's true anymore so I don't
want to you know speak badly about
something that's not true but I mean the
real answer is that it's just not my
thing I mean I have I was like no
judgments at all toward most things but
toward definitely those who like and use
social media I think if it makes you
feel happy and connected to the world
that's great if it's a platform that you
use to talk about the
issues that you're passionate about
that's great but it just generally
freaks me out I'm just a fat Shem
sensitive like shy person and I mean I
still refuse to get a Kindle and only
recently definitely kind of moved all of
my music in a digital land so I think
maybe I'm just born in the wrong era
I've always threatened to go back to a
flip phone but okay you know but I need
Ober occasion shirt ng ng PS no I'm with
your honor
I love the flip phone I actually missed
the flip phone and uh I do too yeah
isn't it great to think like nobody can
email me yeah I mean I remember that all
of my friends forgetting cell phones
when I was in high school and I that my
immediate thought about a cell phone was
like why would I want and able to call
me sure and I'm not at home yeah and now
it's like that thing like that anyone
you have to have a cell phone now I mean
it I mean even the kids in big little
eyes are on their iPad every I know I
know it's crazy yeah I think I mean it's
super helpful I mean I had to go to a
wedding once and like you know Yosemite
and I had to drive up there from Los
Angeles and there's a huge drive and I
did it alone I mean I don't know what I
would have done if I didn't have my you
know cell phone if I didn't have my GPS
I mean that would have just ended really
bad Sarah I think you're selling
yourself short here I think you'd be
great with a map I really thank you so
just on a serious note just I think it's
so impressive and I love seeing stories
kind of like JK Simmons and I think
you're in this boat where you started
getting big gigs later in your career as
an actress and I think a lot of actors
and actresses when they get to a certain
age they start losing hope that they
haven't got what they dreamed of or
haven't ever got that big break or land
of the big role what would you say to
those actors and Irish's that feel like
giving up at this point that they're a
little later in the game and it's not
working
is there some kind of encouragement you
could give them yeah I mean you say that
that hits me in a really like personal
place
and I would say that you know if you're
listening to this and you feel like
giving up I mean you know I'm pretty
terrible at advice but I can say that I
I can empathize because I actually feel
like giving up a lot and this is a
really crazy time to be alive it's a
crazy time to be an artist and it's a
totally crazy business but if you're in
this because you know you love to make
arts you can do that anywhere at any
time with no permission from anybody so
if that's true for you then you've
already won just go make some art but
for your mental health you know for your
mental health separate your love of your
art from the business right now just the
stuff that the stuff that is totally out
of your control and I put a little stock
in luck but Luck's not really in my
control I put a lot of stock in hard
work and practically practically I think
it's it's probably a really good thing
to know where you want to be
geographically when the phone isn't
ringing because that happens for
everybody you know a big advocate is
just do do what makes you happy it all
works out in the end but yeah I really I
really do empathizes with people that
are not quite where they want to be did
you ever see that that documentary of
the Defiant ones no I haven't oh my god
it's so good
where is that where can i watch that HBO
oh that was totally not a plus I can't
but it's really really incredible and
Jimmy Iovine says something incredible
on it he says he talks about how he
tells people that you have to you have
to think of it think of your career like
oh I'm gonna butcher this he says it's
so well but he says you have to think
about your career like you're a horse
with blinders on got to run your own
race
you can't look you look to the side
you're gonna run into the wall you know
just
just run your own race don't compare
yourself to anybody else there's room
for the table and everybody that's
really what I believe that is amazing
I'm definitely gonna watch that now and
Sarah I hope you're right an
inspirational book one day I can't wait
for it
no no way baby too many ARMs in it
nervous nerd laughter that's what that's
okay so to wrap things up Sarah the
question that's on everyone's mind if
you can answer it
will we see tour again this season and
if not will we see her in a future
season what do you know anything about
that
oh I think there's a pretty good chance
that we're gonna see Tori again yeah is
there anything you would like to promote
at the current that's coming up any
projects anything any theater I would
like to promote peace kindness and
conservation and I'll leave it with that
that is beautiful
Sarah that is just amazing note to go
out on thank you so much for joining me
I'm so grateful you did this and it is
super awesome of you and I'll never
forget this yeah yes and everyone please
keep watching big little lies make sure
to share this interview ever you can and
yeah leave a like down below and comment
anything you thought about anything you
want to share to the discussion and yeah
thank you so much you're so welcome